over a hundred thousand people recently
watched the best apex legends
competitors that north america has to
offer
murder each other in what was
objectively a hype as hell
series of tournaments this highlights
the fact that after a year plus
of slowly building momentum apex legends
is having a moment within the wider
landscape of
esports the only question now is where
does it go from here
[Music]
smash those buttons slam your keyboard
off your desk until the dinging noises
start happening
and you're subscribed to the channel for
the rest of your life
and if there's a story you want to see
here on don't at me send a tip
to tips at the score.com originally
announced in december of
2019 the apex legends global series or
the algs
has quietly become a big part of the
game's growth
over the last eight months or so and the
algs championship tournaments that
wrapped up this past weekend
showed that from multiple perspectives
from big name teams like tsm and cloud9
to
underdogs like nessie in europe or
kungara
n a better known as bottom 20 in north
america
the games were fast paced and full of
exciting showdowns
fueled by a prize pool of 690 thousand
dollars per
region well at least for n a and eu
and although they weren't crowned the
kings of n a
tsm and specifically tsm snipe down
gave us one of the nuttiest plays in all
of apex legends history
respawning late game with nothing more
than his heirloom hatchet
sniped down wiped the competition gave
tsm match point
and forced a game 5.
oh my god
here's the clip from pro player nice
wig's perspective he was
calling the tournament for his chat his
reaction
is pure [ __ ] gold honestly how would
they say
john's worth these behind them are going
to be alive sniped out
is still up as well with the kill stop
stop stop leaving me up with that
jesus i'm
now the algs used a match point system
for the finals with
teams accruing points through placements
and kills
match over match with the whole goal of
getting 50 points
which would then trigger match point for
that team
by the time we got around to what would
be the ninth
and final game almost six hours
into the broadcast eight separate teams
were sitting on match point which
made for an incredibly brutal and
nail-biting finish
in the end it wasn't a well-known roster
like tsm cloud9 or sentinels that
took home the championship no it was an
underdog
team commonly known as bottom 20 that
shocked everyone it's a game of
peek-a-boo
and it looks like the move has been made
down for renegades to move in
they will be able to reset here but no
here comes
bottom 20. what a story it would be it's
all down to pow pow can he get it done
for better guys
bottom 20 will be the champions
like prior to this win bottom 20's
best placement at an apex official event
was a fifth place finish at an online
tournament
a year and a half ago but because of the
tournament's open qualifier structure
these recently orgless dudes were
able to walk away with the north
american championship
seriously kungarna n.a announced that
they had picked up the trio on june
2nd just days before the finals started
now
i talked to fallout who was on hand
casting the event and
here's what he had to say about calling
such a ridiculous finals
you thought that we were going to see
the opposite end of the spectrum of
history being made with tsm maybe
winning in four games or five games
because they qualify they got to match
points so quickly
um instead we saw the opposite we saw
the largest and longest series since
poland you know poland went to 11 games
we went to nine
games and every single game every single
moment i casted
game eight with rain day where we had
two teams that were on match point the
one team was sentinels that didn't and
they played spoiler for everyone else
that is just one of a kind height by
using an open qualifier format
coupled with an unusual point system not
only were most games extremely
dramatic but they allowed no-name teams
to compete
which then created exciting as [ __ ]
story lines
everywhere you looked over the weekend
people were stoked on the n a tournament
and europe's before it
cs go fanatics valerent nerds you name
it
it felt like esports had its eyes glued
on apex insane level of competition
imperial hal an apex streamer and pro
player signed to tsm
streamed his player pov to 80 000
people while the official play apex
twitch channel
topped out at almost 70 000 viewers for
the finals on
sunday that's not bad for what some were
calling a
dead game not too long ago here's what
fallout had to say when i asked him
about why
he thinks the algs popped off the way
that it did
so people i don't think people realize
how much apex has been growing over the
last six to eight months
our top streamers have gone from you
know five to ten thousand concurrent
average viewers to 30 to 40
000 and you just seen an amazing amount
of success
um that's translated to competitive apex
because a lot of our top streamers are
also pro players so every single online
tournament
from the winter circuit from the autumn
circuit onwards saw growth so i think
that's a big part of it
two apex in the launch it had is it was
a massive
immediate success i think the first week
here they hit a million unique players
within a couple of days
so most people have either like played
or touched or experienced apex at some
point of the last two years
so when they started hearing this
chatter of lgs championships the 2.5
million dollar prize pool the match
point format how much was at stake
i think it was really easy for a lot of
players to go back like oh yeah dude i
freaking love that i love that game and
i played you know a little while ago
now let's talk about how we got to this
point because apex wasn't
always riding this wave after apex
dropped to some incredible excitement
back in february of 2019
reality quickly caught up see when it
first
launched it wasn't that apex was a bad
game it just
hadn't found its identity yet it
borrowed from a lot of different
first-person shooters
and tried to bring in those same
audiences so the sentiment that emerged
was that while
fun and visually distinct apex felt like
an amalgamation of a bunch of other
games
instead of its own unique thing as its
popularity started to slip
the audience that was engaged started
asking for
specific changes to hopefully make the
game better
and wouldn't you know it developer
respawn did the ingenious thing of
actually
listening to its player base and making
smart
changes that its audience was mostly
happy with i mean you can't please
everybody
from quality of life changes to
overhauling the balance of certain
weapons and
legends to a brand new map to addressing
the game's
massive cheating problem head on respawn
has been remarkably tuned in
to what its audience wants even if it
doesn't move at the pace of say
fortnight and according to fallout it's
this careful and methodical approach
that
has in part gotten apex to where it's at
now
every studio touts like we are community
obsessed player obsessed
respawn as a studio literally since day
one of
of their founding you know of course a
lot of the folks that came from infinity
board originally
have been so kind of player focused
player obsessed
and that stays true for apex they
respond to feedback so quickly they're
so agile in their development i think
the way that respawn structure and the
way that they push out
updates hotfixes and really listen to
the community was a huge part
of the game's success once a community
members saw how much respawn was
adapting to feedback and taking feedback
and making these changes i think it just
drew more and more people in and more
streamers want to play the game and
like speaking about the community the
algs was
partly crowdfunded similar to dota when
you bought
certain cosmetics a portion of that
money
went to the algs prize pool and i think
that
this model well still a capitalistic
business decision made by a giant
corporate entity provides a sense of
ownership to the apex community that
they somehow helped make this all happen
according to ea because of this
crowdfunding the algs championship prize
pool
was doubled from its original million
dollar pot
to two million five hundred and eighty
thousand five hundred and ninety
dollars according to fallout another
major
factor for apex's growth over the last
eight-ish months
is its content creator community with so
many of its top streamers
also being pro players and apex has
leaned
into this hybrid quality by allowing
these pro players to also co-stream
their perspectives during big
tournaments or just have watch parties
with their audiences
while co-streaming has slowly been
adopted in valorant
and even more slowly in cs go for
example
it's hard to see this as anything other
than a
big reason why the algs has picked up
the viewership that it has
sure there's reasons that tournament
organizers are hesitant about
co-streaming
the loss of eyeballs and potential
advertising dollars being a big one
but the reality is this might be the new
reality for esports moving forward
views are views whether they're coming
from shroud hosting
a watch party or from the official play
apex stream
as long as they're watching your game
and your production
what else matters now on top of all this
apex saw a pop with the announcement of
arenas a 3v3 round-based game mode that
was announced
back in may by stripping away the more
plotting battle royale elements of the
game
and introducing an economy arena strikes
a balance between
cs go's tactical thoughtfulness and
apex's
fast-paced insanity and honestly people
[ __ ] love it
reno's so funny all of this combined all
of these
tiny decisions made over months of
tweaking
and changing the game based on community
feedback
culminated in a big moment for apex
and its esports future over the weekend
while the algs has wrapped for now and
nothing new has been announced
fallout thinks that we'll be hearing
something pretty interesting sometime
soon and for the sake of building off
its well-earned momentum
i really hope apex continues to do
cool [ __ ] like this the way that they
adapted with kova to create this match
point format this structure this online
tournament structure
was brilliant something tells me we're
gonna see something really really cool
in the next rendition we don't know what
it is yet uh but i'm excited for it
who knows what the future is uh for
competitive apex i i don't know but i'm
excited to see what it is because i know
that uh the competitive gaming team in
ea is cooking up something great
i had a piece of paper that i wrote
helped me on
and that was gonna be the we
we help help me
yeah help me there we go and uh but then
i turned it into a paper airplane
for the gag this morning
yeah i just had paper lying around where
i wrote help me and it's like tacked to
my wall you know no
i i don't know colton make me look like
an idiot in the end board we got
plenty of things to work with you know